After 50 billion comments requesting me
to do this, I have finally laid my hands
on the RX960
XT
16 GB. What were you thinking, bro? Huh?
Wayne doing that 8 gig stuff. Literally,
last video was 4 gigs. Anyways, with
this graphics card MSRP coming out at
350 USD, it instantly should be one of
the most popular GPUs in the budget
build scene, or at least the budget
minded build scene, cuz I paid €370
for this thing, and it ain't that cheap.
But when you compare what's available on
the market right now, it's pretty fairly
priced, you know, especially because of
the VRAM. But now, is it just all glory
or is there some sort of a catch that
none of us are aware of? So, yeah,
that's what we'll try to figure out in
today's video. And you know, it's going
to be an amazing sunny day when you're
able to run Doom: The Dark Ages cuz for
the past couple of videos, I've been
suffering from a dark syndrome called
low VRAM. Yeah. Anyways, we're going to
start off with 1440p high, which I think
this GPU did a pretty good job in.
50-ish FPS in this game is generally
considered to be pretty smooth, but by
dropping the settings or the resolution
down, you can achieve way better
numbers. Sliding towards Indiana Jones
with supreme preset, the 9060 XT handles
it like a beast with high 70s even on
1440p. And for the 1080p folk, you can
even get into the hundreds sometimes.
Isn't that crazy? After waiting for two
hours for Stalker 2 to finish patching
and compiling shaders, the sweet spot we
found for it was 1440p medium or 1080p
high. The frame rates were basically
identical, which means that you have two
paths. Either higher resolution, lower
settings, or lower resolution, higher
settings. But wait, I guess that always
goes like that. So, I didn't
I didn't burn something. Okay, never
mind. Well, yeah. Moving on, we see that
this GPU also continues to shine in
Blackmouth W F W F W F W F W F W F W F W
F W F W Fukong because on native 1440p
medium, it pulls off a solid 60 plus
FPS. And on 1080p, you can even max out
this card because with the highest
settings, you're going to get around 70
to 80 FPS, which is genuinely impressive
for the price. Perfect. Okay, now can
someone explain why CS always defaults
to 1440p and high settings? Cuz
realistically, who would need like 8K
ultra pro max path traced and ray traced
bricks when all you need is just a
clickhead?
Yeah. Well, on the default settings, we
didn't hit 240 FPS. So, for the 240 Hz
users, those settings are just pretty
useless. But speaking about the
competitive settings, for example, 1080p
low and shadows on very high, this GPU
handles it flawlessly. Just give it the
best CPU you can. So, for example, even
like 7800 X3D, 9800 X3D. Set the
settings to medium or low and just watch
the FPS. You will be amazed. Now, with
Call of Duty War Zone, we're probably
going to start the barring a section
part of the video cuz even on maxed out
1440p settings, we were able to surpass
120 frames per second. And remember
guys, this card is only about 350, 400,
something like that. So yeah, just roll
the benchmark.
>> Here we go again.
[Music]
Cyberpunk really really impressed me
though cuz on 1440p with high settings
and native resolution we were able to
hit above 80 fps and dropping down to
1080p ultra it absolutely makes my and
probably your jaws drop to the floor.
111 FPS for a €370
brand new graphics card. That's insane.
Now, what we've learned from this video
is that if you are strictly looking for
a brand new graphics card, the 9060 XT
is great for its value. Still used
options like RTX 3080 Ti for around €430
or RX6900
XT for around €400 offer more FPS per
dollar. But this thing has features that
other two don't. For example, it is very
small and compact, almost the same size
as GTX 1650, so it will fit everywhere.
Also, it only requires a single 8 pin
connector, which means that something
like a 500 600 watt decent PSU will do
the job fine. You don't need that 1,00 W
plus PSU just yet. And also, as a result
of low power draw, it runs very cool.
Speaking of newer titles, having 16 GB
of VRAM is also helping to have a peace
of mind and also 3year warranty. Now,
that's peace of mind squared. So
basically, if you're allergic to buying
used stuff, but still are looking for
something reasonably priced to have
long-term, this is probably the best
option, as the 5060 Ti costs around €70
more for around the same performance.
Thank you so much for watching this
video and yeah, cheap bastard